Where do you go once the battle is won?
The third episode of Game of Thrones' eighth
and final season "The Long Night," was all
sorts of intense and warning, spoilers ahead
with the brutality and bloodshed of the Battle
of Winterfell nearly taking out our Westerosi
heroes and letting the Night King and his
army of wights and White Walkers roam free.
But Arya Stark harnessed her inner ninja,
evoked the spirit of Azor Ahai, and turned
the battle from a losing one to an instant
success when she stabbed the Night King and
cut off his minions' lifeline in the process.
The side of the living won the Battle of Winterfell,
the dead fell and so too did the Long Night,
and the sun began to rise over Winterfell
once more.
So what comes next?
With just three episodes of Game of Thrones
left and the perceived greatest threat already
eliminated, how will everyone move forward?
Thankfully, HBO hasn't left fans totally in
the lurch after Episode 3.
The network released a preview for the upcoming
episode that offers a taste of the events
to come after the Battle of Winterfell.
And boy, are they going to be wild.
In the teaser, Daenerys Targaryen, fresh off
learning her lover Jon Snow is actually her
nephew and the true heir to the Iron Throne,
states that the Great War is over and Last
War is about to fall upon Westeros.
What war might that be, and what will it entail?
Oh, you know, just a casual storming of the
Westerosi capital of King's Landing, where
Dany will send her depleted army to march
against the reigning queen Cersei Lannister.
The Lannister lioness isn't going to go down
without a fight, of course.
In the eyes of many, Cersei has gone mad with
power — and with grief over the loss of
her three children over the course of the
series.
She may not have dragons, Unsullied soldiers,
the support of very many in Westeros, or those
elephants she really, really wanted, but Cersei
does have someone who matches her hunger for
dominance: Euron Greyjoy.
He's got violence to spare, a fierce loyalty
to Cersei motivated in part by his desire
to continue their intimate relationship, and
no qualms about killing.
Sounds like a perfect match for Cersei, right?
Plus, Cersei has Euron's Iron Fleet and the
Essos sellsword force the Golden Company,
ringing in at 20,000 strong.
She's not exactly the underdog in this impending
battle.
Still, Daenerys and company aren't all that
worried about the fight Cersei and Euron will
put up in King's Landing.
The Mother of Dragons makes it clear that
she and those who fought in the Battle of
Winterfell will win the Last War against Cersei,
unseating her from the Iron Throne.
Addressing those who survived last episode's
battle, Dany declares what the North will
do to Cersei when they sack King's Landing:
"We will rip her out root and stem."
It probably won't be all that simple.
And if and when Cersei is booted from the
Throne Daenerys wants so much, who will be
the one to actually occupy it?
At this point, the battle for the Iron Throne
is anyone's game.
Jon Snow, whose real name is Aegon Targaryen,
is technically the rightful heir, but he's
never expressed interest in ruling the Seven
Kingdoms.
His aunt Dany, who is next in line to the
Throne, doesn't have as strong a claim to
power but wants it so much more and would
sacrifice everything to make her dream a reality.
“Not Dany.
How about my queen?”
Some might try to push Jon to accept dominion,
while others may try to strike him down so
the Dragon Queen can add another title to
her massive list.
The same can be said for what people might
do with Daenerys.
There also exists the possibility that neither
of them will replace Cersei, and someone else
like, say, Sansa will succeed the Mad Queen.
It isn't just the core conflict between the
powers in King's Landing and the forces arriving
from the North that fans have to look forward
to on the fourth episode of Game of Thrones
Season 8.
Get ready for some tense face-offs: Jaime
will stand against his sister after turning
his back on her during season 7; the Hound
will see his brother, the Mountain; and Daenerys
will enter the room where her father was killed
while he sat on the Throne.
History might repeat itself in two of these
instances, with Jaime going from Kingslayer
to Queenslayer by ending Cersei's life, and
Dany being overcome by her father's influence
and slaughtering her enemies without mercy.
She did it before with Samwell Tarly's brother
and father who's to say she won't do it again
when emotions run high in King's Landing?
"The Long Night" is a tough act to follow,
but all the pieces are in place for the next
episode of Game of Thrones to be an all-time
classic.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.